i think a fantastic sunday roast is the
cornerstone of home cooking it's what
the rest of the week's meals are built
around and i absolutely love it but that
doesn't mean it can't be improved
to make the most out of my roast my main
course is the delicious stuffed roast
rib of beef
complete with tangy horseradish
yorkshire puddings
[Music]
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest
15 year old megan to reinvent one of my
all-time favorite classic desserts eaton
mess bomb
right eat a mess what's the one thing
you love about is a mess i love the
meringues now this is a eaten mess
with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal one we're gonna freeze it so it's
almost like a sort of eaten mess bomb
wow now i'd like you to whisk the cream
please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a coulis strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking
is like 10 seconds on
and 10 seconds off
that way your arms don't get tired
now
i'm going to take the cream to a
three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream
that's what we call
three-quarter whip you've got a nice
soft peak
they're caramelized there you go we'll
put a little touch of water in there
that'll help
break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine i'm
gonna blend it
on
and blitz
off
okay that's fine i want you to use the
back of the spoon
and push that
through the sieve okay now that way you
don't get those seeds it smells so good
i love this now nice this is the
exciting part
hold up oh mag
megan
right now the meringue with your fingers
just crush and flake the meringue into
the cream how big should i crush it dado
there
nice big chunks
okay lovely
oh you okay yeah come on rang in my eye
damn
to make this dessert even easier i often
cheat by using good quality shop port
meringues a little taste that's just
cream and meringue
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple of spoons
of the cooling
now look at that now
to prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of clim film
adding water to the bowl will help the
climb film stick
as i pour that in i want you to spread
it down okay at the bottom and push it
down can you hear that crunch yeah the
line all right
now
fold the cling film over
put that in the freezer please
make young please
in the freezer she goes
[Music]
dessert done now for our main course
with a twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so it
sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards so meg and i are
going to avoid that by cooking
everything in one roasting tin starting
with the spinach and mushroom stuffing
[Music]
let's do it with a salt and pepper
please
good girl
some of your left shoulder left shoulder
thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down
and flip very good that's it push down
nice that was lovely and again
nice i'm gonna drop let's see well done
well done well then right we're gonna
sort of make a little well a little
touch of butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle piece
so you can push that down the spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely
good
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
good
mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now tarragon it'll taste
brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish roughly
chop the tarragon and i sprinkle the
fresh breadcrumbs so the breadcrumbs
almost sort of bring the stuffing
together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that
okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
gonna protect it and sit it on a trivet
so a trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that
in i'm gonna pour my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm going to lace mine
with fresh horseradish
[Music]
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but
vegetable all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown
with the yorkshire puddings on the way
and the beef rested we can finish off
the eater mess bomb run the bowl
under the hot water
twist
and pull
nice wow look at that beauty
it's amazing sit that
on
to your plate
now the finishing touches a drizzle of
the remaining strawberry coulis i'm just
going to pour this over
amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate
and that is a nice twist
on a classic eaten mess a delicious eat
and mess bomb
beautiful let's go baby
please don't drop that meg please it's
not a rounders match
dessert sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up lift that up place that onto
the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in halves they've got all that
flavor one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie and then on the side it's
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for
now fantastic yorkshire they're amazing
aren't they beautiful mm-hmm that's for
my daddy
i met one that's for me
beautiful roast beef
with a twist
wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate classics with a
twist
juicy river beef with horseradish spiked
yorkshire puds
and scrummy eaten mess bomb topped with
strawberry coulis and mint chocolate
crispy roasted with pancakes
with the added kick of a black bean
dipping sauce
megan
you're gonna help with the duck danny
your favorite yes it is now how's your
boyfriend
right i'm going
come on that woke you up didn't it
so what do you love most about duck the
dipping sauce the dipping sauce i love
that let's get the duck in the oven
first
let's get a bit of salt in there please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why do you think we pour that in there
season it and flavor it
how come you put them in hole like that
and not smaller it's going inside i'm
not using it for sauce or anything so
it's just going to make it really nice
what are they
star anita sorry
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume aroma inside
tuck that in there
to get it spicy rub
all that chinese fire spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
so make sure you get it all in even the
little wings you know underneath there
just like i used to do to you in the
bath
i used to wash your little handys
i know those days are long gone i know i
know i know
that is seriously spicy
with the duck there's generally quite a
lot of fat there yeah so we're gonna put
it on this little bench
okay
and that
goes
there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside all
that fat is gonna render inside the
breast so therefore it's gonna get all
nice and juicy yeah
right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part
i think it really adds to the dark it
makes it really tasty cena's is your
favorite you can make it i'm gonna do
nothing okay daddy's gonna put his feet
up so
uh first off the garlic there's one good
girl watch your fingers please always do
good
nice
oh you're fast
huh watch your fingers i am
watch your fingers slide slow down
please
14.
all right that's enough
right little teaspoon of olive oil
in a few years time i'll be teaching
how to drive
as well as cook how exciting is that you
know in a car
scary
okay garlic in
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch of black beans
nice
megan and i add soy sauce
and lastly for that classic chinese
sweet and sour element brown rice
vinegar and honey
are you happy with the flavour i'm
really happy
you can taste everything in there
dipping sauce done duck's in the oven
let's start the dessert the most amazing
tata tan are those pink peppercorns they
are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything like black peppercorns quite
sweet aren't they they're really sweet
very fruity the pink peppercorns give it
the sweetness the black peppercorns give
the heat
now
what is that baby
vanilla
this is one of the easiest desserts in
the world to make but one of the most
delicious it's a sort of take on the
classic apple or pear to tan but when
you caramelize those bananas with the
peppercorns
and the vanilla i bet that tastes
amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay i'm gonna make the caramel start
off with the cold pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because i
want the butter to stay cold because i'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those
vanilla vanilla seeds pods in there as
well
okay peppercorns done yeah well done
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally
nice and then look just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter
well do you know what i want the bananas
really caramelized
you just stuck them between
if you crown them in like this okay it
will stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay so all
wedged in there
sprinkle the peppercorns on top of the
banana so you got that flavor
in the caramel and on the top and the
bottom
right
puff pastry
puff pastry is difficult and time
consuming to make so i always buy ready
made when i'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
and this is where it gets really
exciting you get your fingers you just
pinch the ends so you thin the end if
you do that for me very carefully have
to be quick because the heat of your
fingers can melt the pastry how comes
you do it dad because we get it nice and
thin so we can clip it underneath
now take a spoon
and what we do is lift up that banana
and tuck it underneath
see little
like a parcel and see the thin bits of
pastry yeah how easy it is to get it
underneath yeah and that's why you thin
them out
you do it so quickly well because i have
to be quick otherwise the pastry will
melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry that's right
see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on
we'll start caramelizing her
those three little holes are so
important if we didn't put a hole in the
pastry
and it will cause a lot of steam so the
pastry never cooks it just goes really
soggy okay so really important the
caramel is live now we're working the
camel give a little shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts oh yeah see
all comes running down
see yeah i see
now that pastry okay it's like clinging
on to the bananas and so when we turn it
upside down we've got this glove full of
these caramelized bananas
look at that wow
it looks like it look a locky
look a locky ah look at likey got it now
baby
is your birthday soon 15. i've just
worked it out
on my 50th
you're 18.
perfect we should do a joint party yeah
love it twelve two four for the old ones
twelve lunchtime time till four for the
old one so they can go to sleep megan
will go on later come on perfect
here's where i get excited now look at
the color of that caramel so tilt the
pan again see how dark it is now yeah
wow it's gone a lot darker now didn't
take long didn't take long at all
that's nearly ready for the oven but
before i put that in i'll get the duck
out
wow
how's the duck doing
crispy
wow and delicious
see how crispy that is it's really
crispy that's what happens when it slow
cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven 190 to 200
degrees for our banana tartar tan
time to knock up a quick hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that zingy asian punch
some freshly grated root ginger
[Music]
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
and shred in a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in the sweet yummy hoison dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens
wow look at that
so
see now where that pastry is
caramelizing caramel so dark and just
a little tip
gas back on
and that will release it because if you
tip it and it's still sticking
then some of your bananas
will stick yeah so now see when it
starts spinning around like this
moving around
and here we are the moment of truth
when you know your daddy
is the best chef in the world
ready
yeah
wow
the vanilla
how delicious you look at that amazing
smells really good as well
right start to stand out done crispy
dipping sauce
cucumber salad ready
so if you take them and your dipping
sauce take them over thank you i'll take
the duck
don't drop it promise
oh
okay
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes
with a hoisin dressed salad and some
extra oomph from megan's favorite black
bean dipping sauce
now
we all know
you love chicken
i do
but we're gonna do it's a way that daddy
used to eat it in paris okay
now i'm gonna hold that up okay season
inside please why is it yellow
because it's a cornfed chicken obviously
it's corn and if you eat lots of corn
turn yellow turn yellow
now what are those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah a little taste
nice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better
salt pepper in there as well please now
chilies
when you hear that noise
is that made
the seeds have come out try take off the
tops
we're going to add the chilis to the
chickpeas in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest i love my zest
you're absolutely right a little glug
of olive oil
come on holes don't worry about your
nails now
come on baby you can do it
now time to peel off all those wonderful
little buds
see
so
as we stuff the chicken with the fresh
thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that
tarragon what's this
mmm
slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little bit
anna cd yep so imagine that flavor going
into the chicken
that's going to be delicious now nice
soft butter in with the tarragon
is that lovely yeah now i want you
gently to put your fingers through there
and just so we get that butter under
there but i need those small beautiful
little hands
ew
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done i want you
to get a nice handful of butter
lift your hand up and push under
good now see that there yeah you push it
all the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah
butter running down and the breasts stay
nice
and moist and like you
yeah
all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
good and push down
come on
okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic
shall i wash my hands no
not yet
we lay the garlic
onto the tray
now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper that your skin nice and crispy
and then i'm just gonna drizzle some
olive oil that will stop the butter from
burning
and look at that
please open them door thank you for that
there she goes
beautiful good job
thank you really good
nice to see holly get our hands dirty i
think we all agree
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
[Music]
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy peaks
gently fold in ground and chopped
hazelnuts
[Music]
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
[Music]
top your meringues with more finely
chopped hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your towel with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
[Music]
the chickens in the oven and the
desserts sorted now for a big easy green
salad
so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
dijon
say dijon
a nice little squeeze of honey
love honey good a little splash
of
aged
balsamic and this is your favorite this
one isn't it i just like the it has a
nice sweetness but then it has
a better nest to it too nice
next to virgin novel
why do we have to use a whisk not just a
spoon
the purpose of using a whisk
is so it can emulsify and more
importantly you're bringing all the
ingredients together taste
it's so yummy that is delicious
isn't it
a good tip to loosen any vinaigrette and
give it a lighter taste is add a spot of
water
now the juice
of a lemon squeeze the lemon in
nice
now use some butter lettuce
start placing the salad
around the outside this one is a lulla
rosso
okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're making a nice flour and you put
your heart in there
it's just like a flower that's exactly
what i'm trying to do a nice
beautiful flower
now
from there
you criss-cross your avocado what does
criss-crossing do instead of just
sliding down i'll show you now you put
your
spoon in there and look
that's so cool
all these nice little bits i want you to
sprinkle those little bits in here
i'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend is going to be
extraordinary
that romantic dinner the roast chicken
the beautiful salad okay yeah the way
your father taught you
and how nice will that be all three of
us sat down eating at the same time very
nice
[Music]
are you gonna do that with megan all of
you
all of you and i'd grab the chicken
okay
now
look at this beauty
that looks amazing doesn't it right so a
little bit
of
drip drip drip nice what i'm gonna do
now is squeeze
all that garlic
down see how soft
and beautiful it is smells amazing the
lemon that we stuffed
inside the chicken roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through
look at that nice
garlic puree
i'll tip all my
chickpeas
in there from there
some of your vinegar
in
[Music]
now you crush them
and because they're still nice and hot
they absorb all that wonderful garlic
and lemon puree
the rich
delicious creamy vinaigrette
the chilis
i can guarantee you young lady that they
are the best
the finest the most delicious chickpeas
you've ever tasted
[Music]
go on then it's yummy
right
in
now little drizzle extra virgin olive
oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on
chickpeas
and that is a roast chicken
fit for a kingdom
this looks really yummy
let me pass the salad out please and
i'll carve the chicken
whole roast chicken stuffed with
chickpeas so with a big green salad it's
always a winner with your buddies
workmates or family